the other alternative is to say hey no  worries do you have your apple wallet  set up now i wouldn't do that as my  go-to i would do the bank statement and  ach play first because just about  everybody who banks has their banking  app on their phone and a way to pull the  statements and see the account number so  the likelihood that you do that is  virtually 100 this works especially well  for in-person sales because like they're  right there they have their phone you  can say pool cool do you have your phone  on you they'll say yes obviously say  cool pull your banking app up they pull  it up you walk them through statements  account numbers in the top right and you  write it down if you don't do ach go get  it set up so that you can do this to  overcome these issues